finding the root cause of equal rights
for women across the globe who have
their genitals mutilated and can't drive
cars and can't enjoy the same rights
that people enjoy 100% in the United
States and the Western world
respectfully I don't I don't really and
I think it's beneath you to say that
something's beneath me let's argue the
ideas not use this sort of undercutting
tactic I read her book in college I I
don't agree with her everything but I I
very much appreciate her approach the
book that I think I read was the beauty
myth back in college she is CEO of daily
clout CEO where people can share bills
and basically work together online get
only a daily clout dot IO I don't know
they thought I oh I but Naomi whoa thank
you for being here thank you so much for
having me I'm excited to be here I don't
know why you'd be excited to be here but
I'm glad to hear that's not usually a
common response
I mean actually I'll tell you why
because one reason is that you know like
a lot of Americans I'm in a bubble not
of my making because I sort of grew up a
little bit left of centrist and most of
people I know are you know urban yuppies
who are a little bit left of center and
that becomes an echo chamber and it's
not healthy and a you know it's got a
website that's committed to building
democracy and strengthens and mock recei
and it's so so important for us to kind
of talk to people who don't agree about
everything well I can appreciate that
that's where I know you were asking our
book like what's this change my mind I'm
pro-gun thing we did a segment where we
just went on the street and I just put
up a sign and it says I'm pro-gun change
my mind people to sit down or I'm
pro-life changed my mind I'm cool
whatever and it was surprisingly after
at the end of the I'm pro-gun we had
several students at the end of it every
single person was glad they'd had the
conversation and not a single one found
they had a rational argument for what
they thought were proposals for gun
control that doesn't mean that one
doesn't exist but they sat down and said
well I think we should have background
checks and they found out there were a
background checks and they said well I
just I think machine guns should be
illegal and I said effectively they are
illegal and they said well I guess I
don't know what I'm asking for and it
was really valuable a valuable learning
tool for us so let me ask you I know you
wrote the beauty myth
many people call you the the godmother
of sort of third wave feminism some of
you so like with a horse in their bed
equal rights but now there are so many
factions with feminism it's it's some
people say third wave the they claim its
intersectional feminism there are people
who have differing views on transgender
issues how they relate to feminism we
had Leah Keith on here for that so let
me ask you I guess sort of this how do
you define yourself how would you
describe your brand of feminism for
those who might not be familiar in the
audience
sure well let me first I want to say
that I think it's really healthy that
there are so many different viewpoints
within sure feminism because it means
it's a living breathing movement that
people care about and also as I said
before it's really healthy when people
don't all march in lockstep you know
that's how our country should work is
people having different opinions and
educating themselves as you just
described I see feminism as nothing more
or less complicated than the logical
extension of democracy and and my my
brand of feminism if you like is you
know very much descends from the end of
the 18th century when people like law
can pain and Mary Wollstonecraft were
coming up with the ideas that became the
American Revolution and the
Enlightenment ideas like everyone's
entitled to Liberty everyone's entitled
to the pursuit of happiness to the full
development of their human potential and
and that one person should not dominate
another control another so these are the
ideals of the American Revolution and
you just extend those to gender
that's the demonym that I believe in
right you know anything that you you you
mentioned that because I know you're
sort of you describe yourself small-l
more libertarian these days which I
don't think was always the case I don't
want to miss characterize you there but
I've seen you be actually pretty
consistent in criticizing the left as
well do you find um that do you find
that tough kind of a juxtaposition of
obviously the roots of sort of feminism
as it's in the 60s and 70s and certainly
in
sectional feminism now far-far radically
left and becoming more libertarian in
your views is that that sometimes tough
to balance so I don't really understand
the question you just asked because
there were a lot of dependent clauses
and for instance I'm not sure what
intersectional feminism means I was
hoping you could answer either someone
comes in dressed like a lady says it's
hate speech to ask a question
intersection I mean you know I I guess
my instinct is to say it's too often the
case that we live in a world of labels
and you know as I said before often the
labels that are affixed to groups of
people you know we too rarely have the
chance to kind of sit down with those
people so sure if intersectional
feminism means like my daughter's
generation my son's generation which is
growing up more aware of how race and
class effect you know human limitations
on potential and opportunity and not
just gender I'm all for that like I
think the more we try to be nuanced
about where is everybody coming from the
better but that doesn't mean I like
reducing people to labels I think people
are more than where they come from more
than their gender more than their you
can ethnicity or sexual orientation
that's you know that's I think we have
as human beings a lot more that unites
us than divides us but the libertarian
thing is really interesting I really
grew up you know as I said like a baby
of the left you know I grew up in the
Haight Ashbury I grew up in the middle
of all of these very hopeful revolutions
like you know gay rights and and rights
for workers in in agricultural fields
and you know they turned into a lot of
really wonderful things but the older I
get and the more I'm exposed to
different countries and different people
from different backgrounds the more I do
think I feel like I don't want to say
small l libertarian because that's just
another label but I I'm very sympathetic
with the libertarian philosophy
underlying policies it doesn't sure
libertarians always come up with the
best policies and it's no policy that's
usually what they come up with which is
often nonsensical like I'm going I
really respect this group students for
liberté and i'm actually going with my
partner who's gonna be a speaker at an
event in sarajevo at the end of next
week and they're a libertarian student
organization they're like there are
hundreds of thousands of them all over
the world and we get into really great
arguments you know and I'm all for a lot
of things but when they get to like why
should the state do anything about old
people or sick people are orphans then
they lose me I think I feel strongly
that well I have a libertarian profound
number-one respect and it's all I've
been working on really for the last
since 2008 for the Constitution right
that's where my kind of libertarian soul
goes to and we can then argue about
policy and what really surprised me when
I wrote a book in America which was
about the decline of freedoms in America
right and it started with a critique of
Bush but it could people kept saying in
the Obama years what about Obama and I
kept saying thank you for noticing the
consistency I kept saying he's a tyrant
he's dictatorial he's sending drillings
and to take out Americans right without
due process he's keeping Guantanamo open
he's creating a war against
whistleblowers you know there were like
six people on the Left who kept
critiquing kept defending the
Constitution when our guy was in the
Oval Office code was nowhere to be found
I I want it I want it I wanted to frame
this back because we could go a million
directions you know obviously we'll
disagree on that I was a I was in
Guantanamo Bay and saw the prisons and
the troops supporting them containing
them but I do want to go back to
feminism cuz you mentioned libertarian
and kind of your children's generation
so I guess let me ask you this in 2017
since there are so many different sort
of definitions of feminism in 2017 do we
believe I guess or or how would you
argue that feminism the fight for equal
rights we're talking about systemic
equal rights it's relevant is it needed
in 2017 and is that maybe a lot of
people see that it isn't that's why
there are fewer self-identified
feminists even we've seen I guess this
is there more self-identified feminists
than ever in my adult life Stephen and I
guess this is one of those moments where
the women watching this maybe a lot of
the men are thinking why is this
question being asked again in 2017 so
let me ask you you're a smart thoughtful
person do you think there's a reason to
have a movement for gender equality
still do you see any
any problems that women still have that
men don't have in the headlines right
now do you see rapists being convicted
okay questions I just want to show you
both because could I ask a question I
think it was a little more pointed than
your question you mentioned earlier some
clauses
let me zone in more what systemic writes
in 2017 are not afforded to or
specifically excluded from women as far
as engaging in practicing is that is the
question that is really common with my
audience both which rights systemically
are not afforded to women that's a very
fair question because the truth is that
in North America and Western Europe on
paper women have pretty much all the
rights that men do you're absolutely
correct about that in enforcement they
don't and in practice they don't we can
get to that but you're you're totally
right that the second wave you know my
mom's generation fought hard to make
sure that in law you know we have
technically the same right sure but then
you go outside of Western Europe and
North America it's a big world out there
and all over Africa little girls are you
know having horrible mutilations done to
them sure within unity you know the
Middle East and we just saw in Saudi
Arabia woman given the right to drive
but little Clause you actually have to
get a permission slip to get permission
to drive from your legal guardian who is
oh your dad or your husband and that's
that's common practice there sure in
India there are bride burnings and this
is not a religious thing in countries
all over the world trafficking of women
in Central Europe in Eastern Europe you
know on a massive scale
you know women being essentially in
domestic servitude in the developing
world you know shipped to countries like
Dubai and I mean horrible things are
happening where women don't have basic
legal rights I mean the rest of the
world so that's a and B I would say even
in this country you know it's a it's a
tough time because you're right that on
paper we've we've won the war but in
reality we face hurdles and harassment
and violence all day long I mean just
looking at the me to movement that's
erupted
you know half a million people most of
them women
many of men have posted hashtags after
in the wake of the you know Weinstein
case the issue of sexual assault and
rape came into foreign some prominent
women spoke out and now there's this
flood of women saying I was raped I was
insulted no one did anything I was
assaulted when I was 19 I came out with
it you know to save other women 25 years
later on the cover of me up magazine I
was a vicious attacked you know there
there was an EEOC investigation other
stories came out it was not just me it
was 20 years of Yale covering up much of
things we face sure can so just want to
hit the pause button there because you
went into a few different directions all
of which I'd like to explore at one time
or another in this interview so I'd like
to kind of well give give you first
choice here would you rather discuss the
the international women's rights issue
or kind of unpack the domestic sort of
Western whatever you like okay audience
yes well I would say you know obviously
it's terrible at your harass you were
harassed I think Harvey Weiss Weinstein
isn't awful well you were sexually so
good and then harassed afterward when
you came to actually all of that but but
what's really important to know is that
I didn't even know it was a crime until
like 25 years later sure all of my
exposure in education I didn't know it
was a crime until my partner's a private
investigator informs me there was a
crime and I didn't know that you know
what the statute of limitations was and
I filed a police report you know in
October and they lost the police report
I do refile it in April those run into
myself and it's that's why you know if
we go to the other side where you much
it's not a religious thing you know I
have an actual flaw on me so I've had
some run-ins with the religion of peace
yeah for having the nerve to read it's
pretty pretty well intuitive on the Isis
Isis list and cares watchlist so I make
all the top ten lists but you know how I
mean how do you know you're on the ISIS
list like that well I'm sure you know
you've dealt with if you've dealt with a
sexual assault case you deal with the
FBI or you deal with you know
international yeah and you can see me on
the careless right there wonderful
organization so ok so let's go there
organically because I know you talk a
lot about the patriarchy and you talk
about sort of the sociological
conditions I I would say that if we're
going to get two solutions which
do believe that you do I think and this
is why I think a lot of people reject
feminism in my generation is that
there's a lot of a lot of screaming a
lot of angry people and not a lot of
solutions and they just blame men for
problems a lot of times this third wave
intersectional feminist and that turns
men off and then also they become more
anti women it's a vicious cycle so
that's in the western side and the rest
of the world I mean if we're going to
get to solutions
I do think we need to be honest about
where the problem stem and yeah it
happened across the globe but there
really is no example that we can point
to certainly no consistent example of
Islamic society where women are treated
the way certainly that you and I would
fight for as far as equal rights so I
kind of like to take this down it a
quick questioning here so that then we
can let let you have the floor and
examine it we talk about patriarchy
really quickly can you define for the
audience what would be patriarchy I
guess as a societal example and then
more of an individual example do you
think what is P I love your questions
they're like you know we should be like
the middle of the night in the dorm room
like a very male-dominated society
pretty much centered around the you know
the father had figured the patriarchy I
think we can agree it is patriarchy yeah
is that your question well I think let's
move on to an individual example because
I think we can go on that for a long
time but like in an individual example
of patriarchy would we say that a family
where a man is a sole breadwinner the
woman works at home she's a mother
through no choice of her own he's not
very loving he's not very caring he's
emotionally abusive goes out with the
guys doesn't treat her well would we say
that's an example of a patriarchal a
toxic patriarchal house a household I
wouldn't know
okay why not well if she I mean if she'd
the question is does she have choices
right if he has the choice to ask for
counseling
get a job have some financial autonomy
like because of the second wave she has
a lot of opportunities to change her
life that she didn't have 40 years ago
you know she can get a credit line she
can move out she can say I need the
therapist with you or else I need a
divorce she can get a divorce
the libertarian you okay I'm following
it's also the feminists to me right so
she has choices so I wasn't say that
that's patriarchy I would say that
patriarchy may be one of the big reasons
that that man has trouble expressing his
feelings okay um fair enough I'm trying
to get into individual practice so we
can kind of get to the root cause of
these obviously in justices across the
globe now and then we can go to the
United States would we say for example
we're talking about religion Jesus
Christ a man who saved a woman from
being stoned said treat your wives as
equals among you treated a woman as
equal among men was very rare at this
point had no wives committed no physical
abuse or emotional abuse would we say
that Jesus Christ was perpetuating
patriarchy himself actually I think
Jesus Christ was one of the original
feminists and one of the most historic
significant feminists come I'm a big fan
of Jesus Christ historically I'm Jewish
but so is he and president historic
figure
continued they can be pissed go ahead
okay let's bring that in there there's
been a lot of scholarship about the
historical Jesus and he's someone that
any radical Jewish person today or
anyone really would really like if you
know if they like social justice he was
challenging orthodoxies on a lot of
levels he was absolutely about gender
equality he you know the early churches
were one of the first gathering places
where women and men could speak and
worship together it was later that there
was a dictum like Paul wasn't so great
you know respectfully saying that women
shouldn't preach that was later Jesus
never said that and there were Mary
Magdalene was you know there's a lot of
historical research that shows that she
was a teacher and also that a lot of the
things that he was doing like having
slaves and wealthy people and
prostitutes and tax collectors were
reviled sit down together and break
bread together you know that was like a
radical statement about social justice
and social equality was very unpopular
at the time got him killed but I'm a fan
okay I just I'm asking a good good good
so we agree I think we agree on that
point
this is a starting off point Christ like
he said I'm a big fan of organized we
would agree on that people who don't
know that Jesus was a Jew people who
beat their wives back died bad people
okay let's put them aside so this is
Jesus Christ the founder of the faeces
we can put him what about someone let's
say who lived a life who took several
lives some of whom were six not talking
about consummated against their will of
course I am would we say that that would
be an example toxic masculinity or
patriarchy or terminology that would
certainly be differentiating from Christ
this is not a trick question yeah so I
it kind of it's not a quick trick
question but I think honestly Stephen
it's not worthy of you like you're a
really thoughtful person you have a big
platform if you go back find the root
cause of equal rights for women across
the globe who have their genitals
mutilated and can't drive cars and can't
enjoy the same rights that people enjoy
100% in the United States and the
Western world respectfully I don't I
don't really and I think it's beneath
you to say that something's beneath me
let's market the ideas not use this sort
of undercutting tactic okay let me say I
think I think it's a reductive question
has that Sharia because you're talking
about the Prophet Muhammad you're
talking about someone who came out of a
very primitive tribal context just like
Moses came out of a very primitive
tribal context and you're talking about
someone who whose life reflected the the
primitiveness of that tribal area and he
actually a lot of when I studied Islam
in college my teacher pointed out that
for his time he actually created
advances in women's rights and how the
law treated women that's true and I
would say if you go back to the Old
Testament or the New Testament or the
Gospels right that the pauline letters
you're gonna find all kinds of things
just as awful like we don't say oh my
daughter has fornicated I have to stone
her to death anymore well that's right
out of my tradition the Jewish faith and
what you don't say often enough is that
or what we don't hear often enough in
the West and I've traveled a great deal
in Muslim countries and I used to live
in Israel and they speak Hebrew and you
I really know what I'm talking about
I've met with Muslim feminists all over
the Middle East North Africa is that
these are the Abrahamic religions they
are really the same religion absolutely
false and let me tell you exactly why
that's false and this is where I want to
compare Jesus versus Muhammad people who
talk about blasphemy against the Prophet
and I know we're concerned about that
here you understand something the very
religion of Islam is to blaspheme
against Christ the very religion of
Islam 100% sure and let me let me let me
come in here yes I've actually really
really don't and they actually talk
about the book being subverted when you
go back to the blessing of Abraham so
this is the thing I say we respect the
people of the book but then it also
becomes a conundrum because the people
of the book subverted the book and
Muhammad has to come around to correct
the book Mohammed also points out that
Jesus isn't the man he said who he was
didn't say it was a prophet said he was
the way the truth of Light Messiah God
in the flesh so I I don't want to get
into a theological argument but the
point is in practice because Muhammad
like you said example of tribalism
unlike Jesus or Moses who both came
before him and not altogether a pretty
similar area of the world different
practice primitive tribal society as
well sure yeah and I would I would say
Muhammad certainly a worse example
excuse me do you know that Moses had
multiple wives do you know that
do you know that the patriarchs Abraham
and Isaac and Jacob had multiple wives I
mean you read the Old Testament yes I
also know he didn't have sex with her
sighs oh do you know that he had a slave
that that Abraham had a slave that she
passed out into the desert with his son
by that slave and left her to die I was
aware of that I mean I could cite case
after case after case of mystery man
Jesus Christ or Muhammad calling for the
deaths or the of Christians and Jews as
you seen hadith or the abuse of women or
this systemic
a form of laws that we see that forbids
women from equal rights and we're
nowhere in the Middle East
ever have they gotten it right as far as
women's rights and so my issue here is
if we're going to come to talk about
solutions and then we can run to the
Western Hemisphere mistaken historically
Stephen on so many levels yeah go ahead
well you buddy I know you speaking in
very long paragraphs I just wanted to
make sure we correct that there they're
not the same religion and two very
example you're so wrong okay so first of
all you know how deeds are not the word
of Mohammed their commentary so weird in
them so that does the Islamic face a bit
faith abandon hadith or do they use them
in practice they a lot of people debate
hadith it's like commentary in in
Judaism it's not the word of Moses how
much do they value hadith I want a
friendís and how much do they value
hadith do they see it as a holy book
holy word I can't speak for them but I
know that hadith is not the word of
Mohammed and that if you look at the
same kinds of arguments by rabbis about
the word of God in the first five books
of the Torah you're going to see equally
ridiculous things that current
commentators are trying to move past and
reject a II you're widely accepted the
question is the answer is they are
widely accepted they are taught in
mosques across the world is mainstream
yeah and they're all so there's a wide
movement of contemporary Muslims who are
critical of the reductive readings of
outdated interpretations and who are
identifying feminist directions in the
Quran and in the commentary and acting
on those just like in Orthodox Judaism
and if you want to look at I mean you
have to look at all faiths if you're
going to do this I mean yes in
Christianity there were many many
directives of the Catholic Church to
kill Church Mohammed this is the
splitting off categorically said kill
Jews there spawns of the devil they have
horns you know go go clear the matter
was called the Crusades did Jesus do
that no no she did not but did Mohammed
do those things did Mohammed mistreat
women did Mohammed call for the mystery
of Christians there are a lot of
arguments and you really should have a
Muslim feminist on your show that more
advanced sorry and advanced the status
of women for his time and you really
should be in touch with you know Muslim
feminists all over the world who are you
know using early so
Justice norms in Islam to kind of
modernize the faith and so we had
several lined up and they wouldn't come
on the show because of the fatwa and
they feared for their safety that's
that's the reality with the program
quiet or they're in hiding they don't
practice in their same country the way
they would my rolodex to I would be very
open to it but wonderful I in the Middle
East can we find a root cause as to why
women are systemically consistently
always today mistreated and not afforded
the same equal rights we have in the
United States so let me speak to an
historical error you just need Iran used
to be a very egalitarian country Lebanon
is very very progressive in many ways
Egypt women young women with cell phones
ran the Arab Spring you you really need
to go to the Middle East because your
discussion the Middle East I can't kill
me if I go and they they have a new law
saying that critics of Israel can't go
to Israel so you know every religion has
its fanatics right including
Christianity including Judaism but we're
not going to make the world safer by
caricaturing either why don't we make it
safer by lying to ourselves you just
said that Lebanon Egypt are are
progressive yeah so Lebanon is more
progressive in a lot of parts of
Jerusalem where my people you know now
are taking over Jerusalem in
ultra-orthodox ways and saying women
can't be equal women can't go to school
equally women can serve the military
they have to cover up exactly like
fanatical Muslims they can't you know
women when I was living in Israel women
in part ultra-orthodox parts of you of
Jerusalem where I lived
we're being stoned and attacked by men
if they showed their arms these were
Jewish women being attacked by
ultra-orthodox Jews there are crazy
people all over the world that's it's
terrible and I would obviously listen I
think we agree with completely would be
against that practice I don't know that
it's law in Israel to stone a woman if
she shows her arms is it it's law its
law
that you cannot drive a car in Jerusalem
on the Sabbath and when you do drive a
car you're breaking the law
and that's exclusively for women no it's
for everybody but there's an imposition
of religious law you know like you guys
are always whipping up fear about Sharia
law well you know Israel you know a lot
of people have left Jerusalem a lot of
secular people have left Jerusalem and
gone to Tel Aviv or left the country
because you know the influence of the
ultra-orthodox is so strong that you
can't live an open secular life there
you know in many parts of that society
anymore so my point is there are
extremists in every religion all over
the world including in Christianity I
mean I've run into Christians who say
Jesus are gonna go to Jesus and Muhammad
to try and figure out why this not
because you made me clean that it's the
same religion but they are two the two
cannot coexist the teachings of Christ
exist totally mistaken you really need
to read the qur'an that's unfortunate
but it says over and over that Muslims
should respect the people of the book
which are Jews and Christians and it
says that you should respect Jesus you
should respect Mary and you should
respect Moses and I can cite you chapter
and verse I can send it to you I'm very
well I'm very well of the chapter in
verses we've talked about him at great
length they also talk about how the
people of the book have subverted the
book after the blessing of Abraham that
his sons were swapped ok let's get to
the western hemisphere cuz I don't think
we're gonna find common ground I just
have to say you know my people were
rounded up and put I'm gonna play the
card my people around home into into
ovens you know partly because of
anti-semitism that descended from
centuries of hideously I've submitted
teachings that emerged out of the
Catholic Church not from the Jew Jesus
Christ let's go to the Western
Hemisphere because we were talking about
in practice you mentioned no systemic
issues so I was hoping we could say okay
here are systemic issues that we see for
example in the Middle East but I think
we can all agree these occur everywhere
else in the third world or places where
obviously it's just been a historical
account of unequal right so let's go to
the West
world let's go to the United States my
homeland of Canada take your pick kind
of Western wait oh no they have a giant
walking absolute horrible pain Z of a
human being for their prime minister
right now who just said his young boys
are toxic and you want to talk about
screwing up women how about you called
your young boys toxic see how they turn
out see how they tracer absolutely
positively he said his young boys were
much more toxic than his daughters you
can already see it this is this guilt
thing right the sex of this young man
I'm not afraid no I know you're not
listen I'm just gonna speak very frankly
right you wrote that you worry about the
beauty myth you're very nothing guys are
afraid of [ __ ] you're very fetching lady
you're very pretty um so and this is
something that you can say the societal
construct but um men are afraid to even
compliment women now because it can be
accused of being a cat call regardless
you're not my boss so we're not in a
power dynamic where that's a violation
of the law but if you were my boss that
would be you know illegal so it's after
the commercial break Jared no more no
more no more Weinstein playing with the
potted plant I promise you that acai
well I will get over so in practice so
you mentioned here in Western
civilization that in practice women
aren't treated equally could you give me
some examples of that oh okay often some
examples of that that you would point to
because systemically right but in
practice yeah I mean I have a tech
company and so I'm in the tech space and
I think the latest statistic was eighty
eight percent or some absurd percent of
investment money goes into companies
that are not led by women even though
women let companies outperform companies
led by men in the tech sector so it's
you know venture capital the venture
capital world is a kind of closed
economy in which men invest in men
investing in men investing men that
creates a bubble of maleness being more
valuable and a lot of innovation you
know the libertarian side of me is like
well you know America's missing a lot of
innovation and good companies and good
products by this gendered investment you
know direction a lot of it's not even
conscious but you know there have also
been big stories about a systemic sexual
assault and abuse in so
Valley and also big stories about
systemic sexual abuse harassment you
know now we're seeing them come out of
Hollywood but they came out of Fox News
they came out of other big Fox News I
get I get it believe me it was comedy
Mana Bill O'Reilly and Eric Bolling for
four months on this program just like
Harvey Weinstein is they made it into
our monologue every night for six weeks
I don't defend any of it yeah it sucks
and it was bad for the women working in
those companies and and it caused a lot
of damage so those are some examples the
military is another really important the
military because I want to especially
for the audience let's get I'd like to
get away if we can respectfully from
like the anecdotal I would agree on
those but more so if we talk about this
we need to make a reflection
statistically or on the whole because a
lot of people saying well Silicon Valley
isn't necessarily me are obviously
Hollywood it's probably the one place
where that fifty percent divorce rate
it's actually a hundred percent actually
exists in sexual assault and pedophilia
rampant because of secular humanism in
Hollywood but that doesn't affect
everybody out in the country so at large
in practice I think is Russia okay well
there's some I mean if you just look at
um the wage gap it still it hasn't
really budged you know men still make I
think women make I think about eighty
cents for every male dollar even working
in the same jobs and for the same hours
and there is something called the
feminization poverty you know like
that'll be a crux here that we discussed
where does the way and you you must have
millions surrounding you they can google
it while we're speaking what is the wage
gap no no one's allowed to jump in here
so we're I'm aware of the wage gap I'm
aware that it's a number that compares
basically median salary women cause I
could google it I don't have the late
but it's it's it's year after year it's
the Bureau of Labor Statistics I believe
you know check it or you can certainly
see it at the National Organization for
Women peer-reviewed studies it's
narrowed slightly it was 76 cents for
every male dollar when I was in my 20s
and and now we've got like four cents
more for every male dollar so i'm not i
don't see that wage gap that is that is
and we have to we have to discuss this
because this is one of the statistics
that is most in contention and it would
be disingenuous for me to just just yeah
to just to sit here and say oh yeah
because i've talked about on the show
when you're talking about Department of
Labor we're talk about their statistics
they're just comparing average salaries
this doesn't take into account
experience where you went to school
education overall scores how long you've
been in a given job how much time you've
taken off it's not a fair comparison and
I think that's important so I'm sure
that you probably do a lot of to be
about you know those numbers and I've
seen those criticisms raised and then
I've seen rebuttals of those criticisms
and then I've seen studies that were
like literally apples and apples for
instance there have been a number of
studies that show they follow alumni of
the same University in the same
professions and they still make less you
know and it's I mean I look at my own
industry I'm a journalist
you know among other things and in every
major news outlet it's men who are the
publishers and the executive editors and
women are middle management you know
that's pretty good seeing with book
publishing I write books even the women
by 70 cents out of every dollar of the
consumer dollar for books it's
overwhelmingly in every house have been
published by and I've been published by
most of them there aren't that many left
anymore it was men who were publishers
then why so many covers was Fabio on it
that's all I see when I go to Barnes &
Noble but let me go back to this no you
did a bait-and-switch here I think those
statistics are available there have been
studies without giving I would really
like to hear those studies because of
something put you on pause and use my
friend Google to if you have to you can
but because I I'm familiar with most of
the studies again I think ok can we
agree on this the comparison the 77
cents in a dollar that is simply a
comparison of average salaries that
doesn't take into account the other
parameters that you mentioned come on do
not believe that that sums up all the
studies that cannot all the studies the
$0.77 number which is most often you
know Patricia Arquette you know that was
out of date it's now in the eighties
okay so it's now in the 80s now even
though we're getting now into the 80s I
know that you've I think the National
Law Center for for women if I'm not
mistaken it's the name and I know they
often cite an AAA
UW study and when you look at it it
actually the AAUW study since
it was actually closer to the high 90s
as far as the wage gap it was a very
significant amount yeah the same the
same study I know that you referenced
and some of your your literature and I
think it's very very well researched
I've never seen a study that takes all
of these parameters into account and
today or anywhere really in the last 10
years shows a wage gap I do think it's
important because I can't take your your
webcast your podcast yes good go ahead
how many women's you have working with
you well my senior editor in chief is
Courtney Kirchhoff she's my first
full-time hire before her was crystal
Heath after that it's Casey Burnett and
a girl named Nicole and our hair our our
our wardrobe designer and costume
designer is a woman yeah well I just
said central writer the number one
writer number one two and three writers
are women that's that's wonderful and do
they you know there's you you're the
talent so you probably make a
substantial salary compared to the
writers and then they're the tech people
and they probably make reasonable
salaries because they're techies they're
probably mostly male so it sounds like
you've got writers and wardrobe people
who are women and I will bet that the
women's salaries in your company are not
equal on average to the men's salaries
in your company please III hate to do
again I really hope you come back you
couldn't be more wrong we can have
Courtney she talked about it yeah and as
a matter of fact we have had so here's
it's also been a blind recruiting
process if you run a quick Google search
which you can do afterward I know you're
fond of saying that um we do a golden
ticket and the golden ticket is we
literally just send it out to the
audience and it's blind submissions and
I read their writing it is as close to
justice as you can possibly find and I
think Courtney is the most brilliant
writer I've ever seen and outside of me
her and Jared are the highest paid
people in this company one thing I also
don't know who works in the tech side
the people who manage the ads and the
infrastructure on the site I I couldn't
tell you I do know we've seen some
emails come in from women these are
third-party companies but it's not an
even split on my company the women tend
to be higher paid on average then you're
you're doing great you're the exception
to most workplaces that I walk into in
which I can see the wage gap because you
asked me some questions and then I kind
of ended up being a bad scenario for
your argument but it doesn't take up
with you
doesn't take a sari you couldn't have
picked the worst person but it doesn't
really reflect the statistical issue he
won't like her Courtney no one no one
reviles modern intersectional feminism
more than Courtney Kirchhoff of anyone I
know and she's a lady by the way she's a
strong lady
what was it we she arm-wrestled not gay
Jerrod here and of course you did win
but she can squat 200 and I think 75
pounds she's a crossfitter she's not
what you would expect for a conservative
woman she's absolutely feminist strong
woman and she hates being categorized as
modern feminism not saying you do this I
think you've had an issue categorizing
her as a woman yeah but she categorized
as a woman or as she says I am NOT to be
identified by my vagina
she says that not me well this is not
that you have a lot of different you
know it's good that there are a lot of
different brands of feminism out that
sounds like she's a conservative
feminist and I'm all for it it's get my
mic in hold on a sec we want to make
sure that we don't want anyone to say
that we cut you and then cut out like
this is the part where naomi wolf just
made you look stupid and you cut it so
hold on everyone can see nothing up my
sleeves Naomi Wolf her her phone died
what did you did you you're okay what is
this a second phone well is the second
phone or just plugged in it's just
clipped it oh okay all right well listen
we're still this is all could you go
horizontal with this just because we're
getting this weird kind of there we go
thank you very much
all right so everyone sees this we're so
miss wolf can you confirm for the
audience in fact you did not get me off
I kept myself off with my high tech
skills we've had people do that after
interviews and there's a whole second
here's the whole interview and so we
just want to make sure people don't
think we're trying to you totally did
not cut me off my lack of attention so
we were talking about I think before
this female employees which we have in
it we were trying to get back to the the
statistical reality of the wage gap I
think you were there and again my
question kind of if I need to reframe it
here is just what statistical realities
can we point to that there is you know
some really good
recent examples with the Walmart lawsuit
about five years ago during the Obama
administration when and this is
something that you know effects
middle-class women and families you know
even more than elites which I think you
you and your audience would want to pay
attention to I think you ate them I said
it just that you know this is like the
left has been accused of being elitist
and if you know we're not going to be
elitist we should pay attention to what
happens to the middle classes and
working classes and these women were
working and they creaked it the same
jobs as men at Walmart in the same
Walmart's and they were not being
promoted and they were not being you
know giving the same wages and they got
a settlement so that's very common so I
want to be clear here two questions I
just wanted to brief answer so we can
kind of move on from this
was this Walmart wide or the this was an
individual Walmart's people who don't
know it was a specific lawsuit so it was
all of Walmart that was being sued but
obviously the woman who brought the was
a class-action suit the specific woman
brought it so it was women testifying as
I recall across various different
Walmart's but it was the whole company
that was at this found have been
systemically discriminating against
women okay
and the verdict or the conclusion was
with a settlement it was a civil case so
it was an equal employment opportunities
Commission lawsuit as I recall and it
was a money Stallman okay which would
indicate that there's an issue there
that it's eally already but let me just
look around you every time I walk into a
bank you know I see that all the tellers
are women and all the managers are men
you know every time I walk into a
corporation I see that all of the
support staff are women and maybe middle
managers or lawyers are women some but
then when you get to partners it's it's
male and this nice show that well in the
other thing is there's a consistent
fortune 500 company statistic that
really doesn't change that of the
fortune 500 companies the CEOs are 95%
male why why well I think there's a very
very entrenched Oldboy Network I think I
mean these are deep questions to even
I'm sure you're familiar with a lot of
them you know it goes throughout a
woman's lifetime women we still
don't have a decent work family policy
in this country so when you have
children you know someone has to look
after them
unless you're gonna farm them out to a
caregiver and that's something not many
families can afford so often the woman's
making less so she'll be the one doing
the caring and our societies in
structured so that couples can share the
care of children after school or before
they go to school even though in Holland
and in Canada you guys have much better
policies so that's one reason another
reason is and I find this more people at
poor yes if you look at it it's just
this is what socialism happens it just
brings everyone down a certain notch oh
I knew this very well in Canada it's not
as though this has created a bastion of
equality or certainly not prosperity but
we just kind of gone down a couple
points Walmart lawyers managers to
government policy and that gets to the
libertarian and me and you where okay so
do we believe government intervention is
necessary for something that's not
systemic but this is why the why before
matters is it possible or is it your
contention that the reason that women
are tellers and the men are managers
that maybe our CEOs or the reason that
the vast majority of women who enter the
medical field who are nurses but often
aren't practicing physicians which by
the way it's not reflecting that wage
gap that's a big one when you're
comparing professions just says the
field of medicine do we your contention
that that is the case because of as you
mentioned a boys network or could it be
would it stand a reason that's based on
perhaps the women's choices well which
comes first right when there are no good
options and you're a woman you have to
make the choice in a world of bad
options and so you know if you if you're
looking at working 40 or 50 hours a week
in order to maintain your career and
never see your child or quit your job
and stay home and see your child those
are terrible choices you know if you're
in the Netherlands and you get to share
the day off a week that each of you gets
with your partner you know then you'll
work four days a week your husband or
significant other will work four days a
week an each of these spends a day with
your child and there's government-funded
daycare and that sounds pretty good to
me
I have a lot of libertarian instinct
but you know support for families really
does have to come from the government
and I also am NOT a libertarian who
thinks that people like I think you can
have a libertarian government I think
you can have a government that supports
individual freedom and supports
individual and family development and
things like you know support for
families really there's no reason that
we shouldn't have government
government-funded childcare in World War
two when you know the government effort
okay sure the employer is not happy
about it
the person who created those jobs and
people not coming in for two days a week
I don't know I mean I don't think you're
right employers lose a lot from not be
able to attain trained women and women
that they've invested a lot of money in
through current arrangements
we're just men and women cuz you
mentioned in the Netherlands or Holland
sharing it but my point is again we
can't say you know libertine for me and
not for thee at that point we're
basically at gunpoint forcing employers
to into a contract that they didn't
choose to be in and I really yeah I
guess I really just don't agree with you
I mean my my psyche you know I tell my
some son I'm a socialist libertarian
he's like mom it doesn't exist
capitalist I'm like that's not a thing
stop with the knot things no but it kind
of is because if you believe that people
have the right to be totally free then
they should you know then government is
just us getting together and figuring
out a way to create policies that
support our lives seen with capitalism
so I don't see it as a contradiction at
all it's been so much fun but I am a
working mom and my daughter just called
so I feel like we should probably wrap
this up there you go as you can see
people there are no edits I would if you
went off for any final thoughts my
thought on that would be and then I'll
let you take the closing here I would
would disagree with that and I think
again we're basin's in the preset
position that women are tellers that
women's are nurses because there are no
opportunities when in fact there's there
are quotas and they'll actually put
women who aren't science into science
access to these professions that men are
I would say that it's based on choice
and certainly at that point absolutely
and then at that point we're talking
about a government intervention at
gunpoint to fix a problem that was
created through individual choices so I
wouldn't support that and I can't go
with you in the preset position that
it's based on an old boys network that's
the only reason women are nurses and not
doctors even the main reason I would say
it's not the main driver I would say
it's in 2017 it's actually pretty
insignificant I'll I'll try and put that
as firmly out there as possible so I'm
not wiggling okay cool well we agree to
disagree and it's been so much fun
arguing with you and we had heat and
light in the arguments that go out if
you're if your daughter's yeah it's it's
been a great pleasure and I'd love to
come back another time thanks to me give
the website one more time for people
before it's daily clout daily clout it
lets people share live bills through
social media comment on them and change
the bills so let's choose anyone into a
lobbyist and a leader of a political
campaign it's nonpartisan daily clout
Naomi at Naomi our Wolf on Twitter thank
you so much hey did you like this video
it what you didn't oh you're a cat
person well that makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video I you know what crazy cat you
can get back you couldn't you can
comment below too as to why you don't
like it